bonsoir en de bonsoir à tous et
effectivement l'heure de vérité ici à
bâle depuis ce matin tout le monde
s'interroge sur l'intérêt d'être là vu
le prix exorbitant du ticket d'entrée
les francs-comtois évidemment ne sont
pas épargnés par les doutes qui
assaillent le petit monde de
l'horlogerie eux viennent ici depuis 20
ans la société snb a testé à peu près
tous les emplacements pour finir cette
année au premier étage juste au dessus
des très grandes
depuis deux ans l'entreprise est d'abord
là pour promouvoir la marque flip à
l'international où elle n'a quasi non
pas de notoriété pour travailler à
l'export il faut vraiment des produits
qu'ils soient très très reconnaissable
et un petit peu exclusif et tous cas
dessinée talons rouges à talons le
designer pour leap en 73 sahin
particulière la mac 2000 elle est
vraiment reconnaissable reconnaissable
par tous elle a une vraie personnalité
chez l'autre grand nom franc comtois
rescapés de la grande époque on
s'interroge également sur la puissance
du salon pour vendre des montres
alors qu'on fête cette année les 30 ans
du produit phare de l'entreprise
la montre newport ça nous permet quand
même d'avoir une belle exposition
internationale puisque tous nos clients
viennent ça nous permet aussi de voir
des prospects qui ne viendraient pas
forcément nous rencontrer
parce que vous êtes très loin
effectivement s'ils viennent de l'autre
bout du monde donc ça nous permet aussi
de présenter nos nouveautés notre
nouvelle communication de nouvelles
images c'est vraiment un événement qui
est encore aujourd'hui est
incontournable pour nous être ou ne pas
être là c'est aussi la question posée
par les représentants de la chambre
française de l'horlogerie qui cherchent
eux aussi comment faire autrement et vit
avec une conception de salon il ya 15
ans 20 ans en fait je crois que le salon
doit évoluer avec une rencontre à la
fois entre fournisseurs et fabricants de
riz distributeurs mais également entre
marques et leur public rencontré son
public présenté des pièces originales
bref se faire remarquer c'est le choix
qu'ont fait des créateurs français
jeunes ou moins jeunes qui ont investi
un nouvel espace appelé les ateliers un
espace que nous vous présenterons de
m'asseoir